c'est avec les oignons feu alors c'est
pas catastrophique mais c'est un souci
constant des permanents oui bah là on
est tombé sur 4,1 millions de
téléspectateurs pour rappel le lancement
était quand même 1 5 million de 2 donc
là on a quand même une belle chute
donc je rejoins ce que faisait tout à
l'heure c'est vrai qu'on s'est posé la
question de ce qui n'allait pas dans de
vol avait eu plusieurs explications mais
il y en a une qui semble revenir de plus
en plus et même sur les réseaux vous en
parlait beaucoup c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
de pleurs avec les portraits et
portraits c'est quand même un moyen
c'est un peu larmoyant c'est un peu la
thalasso et là c'est une petite compil
alors si vous êtes prêt de deux
médicaments du laboratoire
mettez ça à distance sa peau est dans le
regard des papas il m'a lancé un
challenge il m'a dit si tu réussis tes
examens je te laisserais faire t'amuser
mais je te donne ma bénédiction
depuis il m'a toujours soutenu jusqu'à
son décès at on pas dit aussi la maladie
génétique la plus répandue en france
ces maladies qui empêche donc le sang de
circuler aujourd'hui cette association a
une grande place dans ma vie fait partie
de mon quotidien je
ma mère a accouché sous x donc je ne
sais pas quel et je ne connais pas mon
père m'a plu et j'ai été adopté quand
j'avais six mois mais j'ai toujours eu
seulement que je suis atteinte d'une
maladie au foie faut savoir qu'il ya un
joint dans les cordes vocales et lui
aussi a été enflammé comme le reste de
mes jambes ou encore you
du coup pendant deux ans j'étais en
apnée ya de la joie partout où il ya de
l'arbas c'est vrai que si ça va dans ta
vie ça pas de problème que tu as tes
deux parents et tout est ce que tu as le
droit quand même de passer le casting
parce que du coup il dit mais qu'est-ce
qu'on va dire au revoir et un truc
carrière de ce corps mais bon c'est vrai
je comprends la politique de mettre le
portrait mais laissez les gens chanter
et épreuve le portrait non non non c'est
alors la santé des notions escales trop
de pleurs selon vous oui non alors pour
moi ya pas trop de pleurs et j'adore
l'idée d'avoir un portrait avant dans ce
voyage parce que du coup on se sent en
ce sens envers la personne on voit on a
les mots tout simples à faire ça non
mais on allait en finir chez moi je dis
je sais pas j'ai accouché sous x à
chaque touche suis d'accord le principe
c'est de juger les gens uniquement deux
sens sans avoir d'informations sur la
voie et on vous met pernikoff mais ce
qu'on aime bien par ces tremplins
musicaux d'ailleurs vous avez connu les
nouvelles stars ce sont des amateurs que
vous suivez de semaine en semaine
oui et qui vont se professionnaliser
rien aujourd'hui on démarre avec des
gens qui sont déjà pro donc la télé si
cette heure pas tous un bon pour moi
même pas mais le téléspectateur n'y
croit plus tout simplement c'est à dire
que à un moment donné quand vous
regardez le programme
il vous arrive plus rien il ya plus de
surprises ya plus à regarder ma elle qui
a gagné elle a démarré elle chantait pas
hyper bien ils l'ont sauvé ayez tout une
histoire où adrien parce que vous êtes
chanteur vous vivez de votre patience et
ça c'est votre métier de voice est ce
que ça vous aurait tenté ou pas oui ça
me tente
après moi je ne pense pas qu'il me veut
parfois la raison pourquoi je sais pas
trop mais peut on poser que le foot
fauteuil est un frein pour les vols se
parle en mon fauteuil non au contraire
parce que tous les ans il ya un handicap
et un arabe il ya un noir il
[Applaudissements]
elles sont pas évoqués la maison sur ce
terrain mais c'est la vérité de va
presque bien
la diversion mais tous les pressions
baissières x men se parlait nicolas mais
à chaque fois il faut qu'ils leur match
décalé vous auriez envie de faire
franchement c'est un bon tremplin c'est
un gros tremplin pour qu'entre n'est pas
connu pour tromper sur ses parties de
vesoul est de dos et vous je vous
chanter je me serve ou non
6 mais xavi bella cosa
[Applaudissements]
élevé au même moment
c
merci benjamin mais là aussi pas qu'il
n'ya pas que les communes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et l'horreur et la mémé pourquoi si vous
voulez bien y'a pas que les candidats
aussi qui pleure et a quand même les
membres du jury qui pleure beaucoup ça
fait un petit bout on vous donne une
paire je la saisis avec lyon ça j -c des
images d'une longue histoire en fait mes
parents sont réfugiés espagnols ils ont
fui la dictature iger dans le franco
pour venir en france pour chercher de la
liberté de mon grand père mariano obispo
a été aussi obligé de de s'exiler dans
le médoc comme beaucoup de basques voilà
si je me suis retourné aussi c'est parce
que ça m'a touché bordeaux pascal tienne
grand bien de se dire que monsieur marc
lavoine vous avez posé la bonne question
en nous demandant d'où venait cette une
chanson qui nous est chère est posé la
bonne question du coup je pense qu on
est d'accord pour travailler avec lui
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que délégué général c'est
qu'une bonne saison banon
j'avais un chat dragon dans des gens
sont globalement assez content le jury
ça fonctionne bien
il est suivi sont pas complémentaires au
replay 1 il faut un demi million
supplémentaire sur le j + 7 et sur les
directs
tout change ils ont tourné au palais des
sports en forme de mini concert
[Applaudissements]